what's going on guys this is rob and i
just wanted to make a quick video
letting you guys know that i have rob
explains officially online here on
youtube that is a channel that I have
designed strictly for me to explain
things outside of the context of comic
books so yeah um head over there to
check it out i'm actually doing a
dinosaur thing this week so it's like i
explained the most of which is the water
dinosaur from the trailer that eats the
shark and then i'll be explaining the
Velociraptor and i'll be explaining the
Tyrannosaurus Rex and stuff like that
and then after that we'll get into some
other things too so make sure you guys
head over there there will be a link in
the description and a comment i guess
and annotation on the screen and yeah so
I'll catch you guys I do please or i
will see you guys over there peace